[Musique]
je m'appelle timothée charpentier g37 en
auto entrepreneur j'ai démissionné de
mon ancien travail où j'étais ingénieur
environnement soudan du sud donc en
afrique
je travaillais dans le traitement des
eaux je voulais rentrer un être plus
présent la dir pour mes proches et aussi
ce qui me manquait beaucoup c'est faire
quelque chose de mes mains je
travaillais beaucoup avec ma tête mais
j'avais l'impression que je ne savais
rien faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me suis lancé dans la savonnerie
artisanale j'ai été un petit peu suivie
par la bce
le bureau de gestion il ya eu ce soutien
par rapport à aller courir à droite à
gauche pour chercher des intentions de
vente un petit peu chiffrer le prix du
de la petite entreprise j'ai commencé la
taça british au pays avec vraiment comme
axe les équipes de la terre de la
culture qui sont prendre soin de
l'humain à travers des produits de
qualité
son dauphin de la terre mais vous
trouverez aucun plastique au pas
d'emballage et partager les surplus
toutes les chutes de savon je les
distribue à différentes structures
sociales notamment la maison de l'amitié
à saint paul qui était une structure
d'accueil de jour de sdf dont qui
propose un petit déjeuner et une douche
du coup avec nos savons j'essaye
d'intégrer un maximum de produits issus
de la réunion planté à la réunion donc
toutes les huiles essentielles viennent
de saint gilles les hauts
elles sont produites en bio le curcuma
que j'intègre dans les savons et
certains shampooings vient de la plaine
des grègues il ya un bon exemple
justement d'un produit vraiment pays
parce que ça intègre du curcuma bio
enracine maire de la plaine des grègues
avec de l'huile essentielle de 4 épices
qui vient justement de
saint-gilles-les-hauts de chez madame
vitry c'est très important justement
pour moi dans ma philosophie d'avoir une
démarche globale où je peux avoir une
entreprise qui génère des bénéfices mais
qui aussi prend soin bas de l'humain de
la terre
un post a chance serre ton bonheur et va
vers ton risque à te regarder ils
s'habitueront
[Musique]
je m'appelle pauline du veau j'ai 31 ans
et je suis la créatrice de la marque
rayonne qui propose donc des des
infusions aux saveurs réunionnaise alors
ces dernières années j'ai surtout occupé
des postes de commercial et des postes
marketing dans les secteurs de
l'hôtellerie de la gastronomie en asie
et en france
ça me tenait à coeur de revenir à la
réunion de monter une marque qui mettra
en valeur le patrimoine réunionnais et
de retrouver surtout mes racines
pour la création de mon entreprise j'ai
été accompagné par la chambre des
métiers de saint pierre pour la création
le montage de mon dossier tremplin
activités des jeunes ça m'a permis de me
lancer de faire l'acquisition du premier
matériel pour la production des thés
soit vous proposer avant tout c'est un
voyage à travers les paysages
réunionnais et on a envie de vous
emmener à la plaine des grègues on a
envie de vous emmener au piton de la
fournaise avec un mélange qui va être un
petit peu et puis c'est chaud à la
rivière langevin avec un thé vert qui va
avoir des notes de jeanne rose à de
letchis qui va rappeler ce côté très
végétal du lieu et puis voilà notre
ambition c'est vraiment de vous montrer
toute la réunion toute la richesse de
nos paysages et on propose donc une
gamme de
8es et infusions aujourd'hui on continue
à faire grandir cette gamme en fonction
des inspirations qui nous viennent alors
rayonne c'est le produit pays par
excellence parce que d'une part tous
numérotés sont créés et fabriqués dans
notre atelier artisanal de saint pierre
d'autre part tous les fruits et tous les
épices que nous utilisons viennent
exclusivement de la réunion je parle
même de la cardamome dont on ne connaît
pas vraiment l'existence sur territoire
réunionnais mais qui existe notamment
tremblay et puis on travaille aussi avec
des agriculteurs qui sont en agriculture
biologique ou en agriculture raisonnée
et qui nous fournissent des fruits
lorsqu'ils sont au mieux de leur saveur
tous ses fruits et ses épices que nous
utilisons nous laisser chez nous même
dans notre atelier 200 billets
c'est toute la richesse de notre terroir
et de nos paysages qui rayonne à travers
notre thé
[Musique]
le produit pays a été mise en l'air à
l'issue de la finale du challenge et
créateurs dans le jardin de la villa du
département
timothée charpentier son entreprise
tissot pays remporte cette catégorie
[Musique]
le samedi avec sanitaires